lobby of Ramsey solutions John and Susan
are with us hey guys how are you hey you
done better than I deserve welcome to
Nashville where do you guys live
actually Dave we live in Gator country
okay cool
very cool well welcome good to have you
so how much dad have you paid off
$142,500 way to go and how long did that
take you 22 months excellent making what
kind of money I'm starting at about 128
thousand and now we're about 158 good
job what do you guys do for a living I'm
an occupational therapist and I'm
retired from the Navy and also I do IT
consulting Oh fun well thank you for
your service excellent so what kind of
debt was the hundred and forty two
thousand dollars student loans were
about thirty five thousand car loans
thirty thousand and then 401k loan and
arrest credit cards Wow okay yeah so did
somebody go back to school well the
student loans come from one was my
student loan that I was carrying around
forever then another was one that I had
for my daughter oh okay all right
carrying around forever how many years
probably
I guess maybe 16 years okay so you guys
recently married is that what that
indicates or no um no no we just had our
30th anniversary okay all right so what
happened 22 months ago well Dave I think
our story like a lot of people I've
heard recently kind of began back in
2008 when that when the market changed
you know we thought we were doing great
we were living the dream and working and
enjoying ourselves in Gainesville and
John lost his job like many companies
were laying people off at that time and
also you know I've heard you talk about
you know having an umbrella because it's
going to rain well life rained on us at
that time my father got sick
my mom had dementia so we had both of
them to care for at the same time that
John had lost his job and we were
spending a lot of times going back and
forth between Gainesville and Brandon
where we
now and continuing to live on credit
card debt to try to maintain our
lifestyle and we had a house that was a
fixer-upper so we were financing a lot
of remodeling on the credit cards so you
know just all of a sudden it just kind
of snowballed all down on us and we just
we were swimming and so what was the day
that this occurred I mean what was the
wake-up call the the window light switch
flipped because it you know it's pouring
down on you but sometimes people don't
even get it then so what what is the day
do you remember what happened I think
that you know it really was when we was
probably 2013 at that point we've still
been struggling along I had taken a
second job to trying to keep the wheels
on the bus but we had gotten down to
$300 in our savings account and I just
absolutely could not breathe anymore I
just was like my gosh we make so much
money and we're we're working so hard
and we we can't we can't do it and I
kept driving by a Financial Peace
University sign at Riverview Methodist
Church kept going by there and finally I
said to him you know we've got to do
something so we signed up for FPU ah
okay and you go in there kind of kind of
beat down I'm kind of going this is man
I'm making 125 thousand dollars I got
300 bucks right this sucks
something different and so what happened
the first night tell me what how'd you
feel and you know what was the the turn
of events well actually for me Dave I
just didn't really believe it was gonna
change anything yes I was so used to
everybody tell me a way to change my
life to get out of debt and no it never
worked so really I was pregnant you know
not very optimistic anything was going
to change and I think when you know when
we got into the class there's such a
healing thing about being in there with
a group and I really think that that
made a huge difference for John but for
both of us that we you know when we
tallied up at the end of the class I
think it might have been the second
class how much debt the whole class had
I knew we were not alone yeah I knew
somebody else in there was seriously you
don't feel so stupid when you're around
us
it's amazing because you kind of think
you're the only one that's a screw-up
you do you know and then when you're
sitting you go look at those people they
look like they got all together and
they're screwed up - absolutely and it
doesn't give you permission to stay
there but there's a sense of release of
the shame or the guilt hidden there
that's very very true and I think that
for John and I I think you know I know
I've heard you talk about the powdered
but syndrome I think there's something
that occurs between spouses that you
can't receive sometimes encouragement
from the other spouse but when you're in
a group dynamic like that and you hear
other people talking about you know
their willingness to try something crazy
like getting rid of the cable or
whatever then then then your spouse can
receive that in a way maybe that they
couldn't before so the group aspect of
FPU was I think huge for us
yeah absolutely John how far into this
before the hope started coming back
alive I think once I started actually my
wife using technology on me and I broke
up an Excel spreadsheet and I actually
started telling everything up and then
we started hitting a debt I think that's
what really changed it because I paid
off the first build the first month and
you start seeing the numbers coming down
automatically
yep that's what changed me yeah and then
I finally had hoped I said okay you know
we can do this and of course listen the
Dave Ramsey show and also I think what's
changed for me now too is Wow reading
other books to like you know the million
or next door and all that always keeps
me going yeah absolutely yeah I had to
kind of I caught as a therapist you call
it therapeutic manipulation I said you
know what if we got one of those
antennas like people used to use what
have you put that up and we hooked it to
the TV and everything and then we could
could would we would you get rid of the
cable then so all of that kind of helped
and I think him doing the spreadsheets
and all really helped but then he's just
gone crazy with this we had these great
detailed Excel spreadsheets we have
every dollar now on our phone so that's
helping out a lot and it's just it's
been it's been incredible we're totally
different people
I mean if this was a 12-step program
we're here to get our chip you know and
I mean we're
sobriety chips that's it that's it I
love it that's perfect
excellent that's very good that that's
it that's where you are you're the
heroes you've you've won the we've won
the race and you get to get the trophy I
mean that's what you're doing here today
but it's a great story too and I really
love hearing that the group idea around
Financial Peace University is
encouraging also kind of hold you
accountable after a while absolutely a
little further down in the class I
doesn't happen like the first night or
anything but you know you get down there
that 8:00 the week and you you know
you're screwing off somebody call you on
it absolutely so yeah so very good you
guys how does it feel now after 30 years
your debt it's actually pretty hard
because we're still Dave Ramsey if I'd
shout out to all my co-workers at South
Bay that have listened to me the
hospital that I work at and my Dave isms
for the last couple years and they all
got Total Money Makeover books all the
family all the but they've really
listened to us and it's funny because
anytime I'm talking about I said you
know we're going to go to to Tennessee
and and they were all like well would
Dave approve of that John and I do that
a lot what would Dave thinks it's kind
of its kind of its kind of code for is
this common sense yeah very good
congratulations you guys all right John
and Susan Tampa Florida hundred and
forty two thousand dollars paid off in
twenty two months making 128 to 158
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
way to go you two I love it I love it I
love it